[Music]
on this Monday night a mass shooting at
an Ontario condo complex the victims
once the officers arrived they were met
with a horrendous scene the 73 year old
gunman and the lawsuit he filed against
his building's board
plus the January 6 committee's historic
decision the criminal charges being
recommended against former president
Trump crime against humanity the
Netherlands apologizes for its
involvement in slavery the Dutch State
enabled and stimulated slavery and
profited from it why critics say sorry
isn't enough and ancient designs just
discovered what's been hiding in plain
sight in Peru for centuries
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Sophie Louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a violent Rampage
at a condo building in Vaughn just north
of Toronto five people shot dead a sixth
is in hospital and the suspect also a
resident of the building killed by
police officers arrived to find a
horrific scene
with five deceased victims having been
shot and killed in three separate units
as you're aware there was an interaction
between the officers and the 73 old male
suspect a resident of that building who
died on the third floor
Mike drulay has the latest on what we
know about the victims and the suspect
who had been locked in a bitter dispute
with the condo board
it took police just over three minutes
to arrive on scene after the 9-1-1 call
somewhere inside this vast condo Tower a
single gunman was on the loose forcing
residents to evacuate and as I started
to go downstairs I heard four shots four
loud Shots by then the gunman who has
been identified as Francesco Villi had
already visited three separate homes
with a handgun killing five and wounding
a sixth police confronted and killed him
on the third floor the officer in that
interaction is a 24-year veteran of York
Regional Police
and he very likely saved lives by his
actions last night the 73 year old man
who was shot by police was well known to
his neighbors to whom he complained
often he was also prolific at posting
videos on social media and over the last
few days they appeared increasingly
disjointed indeed when approached today
residents painted a picture of a
troubled man who was quick to anger we
all felt threatened all the time I got
scared of him so whenever I saw him I
would evade him Billy's issues according
to multiple neighbors began over seven
years ago when he complained of a hum
emanating from the electrical room
beneath his unit the Florida White
Bridge in the morning
I tried to sleep under my bed this was
all sleeping
and then the Moon
because my bed trembles your bastards he
sued the condo Corporation as well as
specific board members for torment and
torture that cannot be explained in
words the suit was dismissed as
frivolous and vexatious three of the
victims were members of the condo board
which decided to try and get him evicted
that hearing was supposed to be today
former board member John Santoro says he
tried to help villy over the years he
wasn't a monster a fact he says that
likely saved his life I know the history
and I know the man I know the board of
directors I know this has been brewing
for a long time and I've commented to my
wife several times this is going to end
very badly sadly he was right Mike drlay
Global News Vaughn Ontario
and just outside of Vaughn in Toronto
police say multiple people were
assaulted by a woman at a subway station
this morning Toronto police say an
off-duty officer managed to detain the
woman until police arrived and arrested
her paramedics say one person was taken
to hospital with minor injuries there
have been multiple incidents of violence
on the TTC in recent weeks including the
stabbing death of one woman and other
random attacks on passengers
in Washington the January 6 committee
made history today the panel voting
unanimously to refer criminal charges
against former president Donald Trump
claiming he was at the center of plans
to overturn election results and his
actions led to the incitement of fatal
violence at the Capitol two years ago
Jackson prosco reports on the
investigation and its recommendations
the January 6th committee ended its work
by making history referring former
president Donald Trump to the Department
of Justice for criminal prosecution we
understand the gravity of each and every
referral we are making today just as we
understand the magnitude of the crime
against democracy that we describe in
our report but we have gone where the
facts and the law lead us and
inescapably they lead us here
the extensive body of evidence about the
attack on the U.S Capitol came from
months of hearings 1200 interviews and
dozens of subpoenas leading to the
recommendation Trump and others be
charged on four counts obstructing an
official proceeding conspiracy to
defraud the United States conspiracy to
make a false statement and most
seriously inciting an Insurrection if
convicted Trump could be barred from
ever holding office again no man who
would behave that way at that moment in
time can ever serve in any position of
authority in our nation again the
criminal referral is non-binding the
supporting evidence may be used by the
Department of Justice where a special
counsel is leading two investigations
into the former president over January
6th and his alleged mishandling of
classified documents I think the doj is
closer to the end than the beginning
they know that they can't wait forever
here because you're going to run up
against the 20 24 election the committee
also dropped hints about other potential
crimes namely witness tampering alleging
trump-backed attorneys offered key
Witnesses high-paying jobs the witness
believed this was an effort to affect
her testimony and we are concerned that
these efforts may have been a strategy
to prevent the committee from finding
the truth the select committee stands
adjoined though the committee faced
criticism for focusing almost
exclusively on the role of trump
its final report released later this
week May offer more insight into the
role that others played
documenting one of the darkest chapters
in modern American history for all it
investigated the committee also laid the
groundwork for avoiding another
attempted overthrow of democracy in the
coming days lawmakers will vote on
changes to the Electoral count act to
more clearly define the powers of a vice
president in certifying elections
closing the loophole that Trump
attempted to use on January 6th Sophie
Jackson prosco in Washington Jackson
thank you
and as the January 6th committee wraps
its findings against Trump Washington is
preparing for the trial of five members
of a U.S based proud boys for their
alleged involvement in the January 6th
Capital attack jury selection for the
trial began today the members are
accused of sedition the prosecution will
argue the defendants plotted in advance
of January 6 to stop the lawful transfer
of power from Donald Trump to Joe Biden
and that the leader of the group Enrique
atario put together a hand-picked crew
to lead those efforts sedition carries a
maximum sentence of 20 years
well the holiday travel season is just
starting to ramp up and already the
warnings are out to expect long delays
through the weekend and today more
Canadian flights were delayed then
departed on time cold weather is slowing
down operations at Major hubs like
Calgary Edmonton Toronto and Vancouver
ongoing labor shortages mean Airlines
and airports just don't have anyone to
call in for backfill let alone increase
Staffing levels
and people in Metro Vancouver are being
warned to brace for another significant
snowfall while still digging out from
the latest wintry blast over the weekend
as much as 30 centimeters fell on the
region making many roads dangerous the
forecast calls for temperatures across
BC to dip into the negative double
digits for much of this week
Rising anxiety in Ukraine coming up the
fresh fears Belarus will back Russia in
battle
plus frightening flight the trip that
sent some people to hospital
and fortnite fine why the maker of the
video game is being ordered to pay up
[Music]
the Canadian government has started the
process to seize assets belonging to a
high-profile Russian billionaire the
government first announced sanctions
against Roman Abramovich back in March
now it's pursuing the forfeiture of 26
million dollars from a company owned by
the oligarch called Granite Capital
Holdings Abramovich who is worth an
estimated 14 billion dollars has long
been seen as an ally and financial
middlemen for Vladimir Putin and is the
former owner of Chelsea Football Club
any money recovered by Canada will be
given to Ukraine for reconstruction and
compensation in and around Kiev people
woke this morning to a string of
powerful explosions with a large-scale
Russian drone attack on Ukraine's power
grid as Crystal commencing Reports the
strikes come as the Russian president
meets with his closest Ally the leader
of Belarus
reduced to rubble and searched for drone
remnants this was once the home of an
elderly couple
there was one very loud explosion and we
did not really know how it would end for
us
inside what's left of their home oha's
daughter-in-law calls for the family dog
she knows it's likely buried but she's
grateful her parents survived
the home about 40 minutes south of Kiev
is believed to have been hit by a
so-called Kamikaze drone
the family hands over anything that
could confirm the cause of the explosion
attacking civilians is a war crime
Ukraine's prosecutor General's office
has registered more than 54 thousand
possible war crimes and acts of
aggression by Russia
Tuesday will Mark day 300 of Vladimir
Putin's three-day Special Operation the
Russian president was in Belarus Monday
visiting with his closest Ally President
Alexander lukashenka
in Ukraine there are fears Belarus is
getting ready to join Russia after
deploying troops along the border
while addressing a uk-led group of 10
northern European nations the Ukrainian
president implored his allies to keep
sending modern weapons thank you for so
powerfully highlighting
the incredible humanitarian cost to your
people a series of aerial assaults going
back to October have targeted the
country's power grid causing sweeping
blackouts in freezing temperatures
Ukraine's Emergency Services released
dramatic video of a fire at a power
station said to have been recorded in
the early morning hours Ukraine's
National Energy company says it will
soon be able to make repairs at
substations and stabilize the power
supply SEL an American company
fabricated and shipped more than 100
pieces of equipment
specially made for Ukraine's needs
Crystal gemancing Global News London
after weeks of debate the European
Union's energy ministers have agreed on
a price cap of Russian gas the system is
complicated but at its core it will cap
the price EU Nations pay for Russian
natural gas at 180 euro per megawatt
hour the prize today is sitting at 109
Euro the goal is to end Russia's ability
to hold the European energy Market
hostage and prevent a repeat of August's
huge price spikes
31 Sailors are missing after a Thai
warship capsized and sank overnight 75
members of the crew have been rescued
the 77 meter Corvette was caught in a
storm in the Gulf of Thailand and its
electrical system failed leaving the
crew unable to steer or pump out water
search and rescue efforts are ongoing
but the odds of finding any more
survivors are not good passengers on a
flight to Honolulu were rocked by a
severe turbulent Sunday seriously
injuring 11 people
if you need people to carry bags out use
the ollie back there
the incident happened about a half hour
before the aircraft landed of the 278
passengers on board responders treated
36 people injuries included head wounds
lacerations bruising and loss of
consciousness officials with Hawaiian
Airlines called it an isolated and
unusual incident saying they will
conduct a thorough investigation of the
plane before it returns to service
epic games maker of the hit video game
fortnite has agreed to pay 520 million
dollars U.S in fines to Consumers and
the U.S government in an agreement with
the Federal Trade Commission epic will
pay 275 million in government fines for
Gathering personal information of
children under the age of 13 without
receiving their parents consent the
other 245 million will be refunded to
users for misleading them into buying
paid content it's the largest settlement
in FTC history
biodiversity breakthrough just ahead the
details of the draft agreement from
Montreal's cop 15 conference
[Music]
there's been a breakthrough at the un's
biodiversity conference in Montreal
after weeks of exhausting and sometimes
tense negotiations delegates reached a
draft agreement on protecting Earth's
ecosystems that includes fulfilling
ambitious so-called 30 by 30 goals the
New Deal means nearly 200 nations are
committing to protect 30 percent of the
world's land and 30 percent of coastal
and Marine areas by the year 2030. teria
Israeli takes a closer look at the new
pledges and just how feasible they
really are
at 3 30 in the morning exhaustion gave
way to elation
cheers erupted when delegates finally
reached a deal on protecting the planet
from self-inflicted disaster we are
finally starting to forge a pispect with
nature The Pact includes 23 targets the
main pledge is 30 by 30 conserving a
third of land and water by the end of
the decade this moment represents a
historic win it it is a win for
biodiversity it is a win for people and
it is a win for climate Canada hosted
and China led the summit which was
delayed by two years because of the
pandemic the goal saving nature from
climate change and development the
framework includes a commitment to cut
500 billion dollars in subsidies to
industries that pollute slashing
pesticide use in half and nearly
doubling worldwide conservation spending
to 200 billion dollars biodiversity is
declining at its fastest rate in human
history with a million plant and animals
species at risk of Extinction while the
delegates all agree on the need to save
them there were disagreements on who
should foot the bill developing
countries walked out of talks last week
demanding wealthy countries helped them
fund the plan the Democratic Republic of
Congo home to the world's second largest
rainforest tried to hold up final
approval I was there on Friday just like
you know just a few days ago wasn't
clear it was going to land some
scientists worry there's too much wiggle
room well I I believe that we can go a
long way if the agreement is implemented
that's always the issue right the
previous agreement failed to fully reach
a single one of 20 Global targets so
that doesn't happen this time the
Liberals promised to bring their plan to
Parliament next year very transparent uh
um legislation and and forcing the
government to be account accountable for
for what we're doing and how far we're
progressing towards our goals goals to
halt
halt diversity and high expectations
this historic deal will deliver tariya
isri Global News Ottawa
also in Montreal some residents have
found themselves homeless for the
holidays the exterior wall of an
apartment building fell away exposing
the entire unit to the street the fire
department says it's possible the
structure was damaged after the
demolition of a neighboring building
earlier this year today Crews were on
site doing temporary repairs the wall
collapsed on Thursday and after three
days of shelter provided by the Red
Cross residents will need to find
somewhere else to stay until structural
repairs are complete there's a new
discovery near Peru's Nazca plain drones
and aerial photographs revealed 168
previously undetected figures carved
into the ground the geoglyphs show
humans llamas and alpacas orcas snakes
and cats along with other animals the
line drawings are much smaller two to
six meters in length on average than the
famed Nazca Lines nearby the lines are
more than 2 000 years old their Origins
and purpose remains a mystery
[Music]
tune to the Dutch Dutch professors slave
trade apology
apology an historic day in the
Netherlands the Dutch prime minister has
apologized for the country's role in the
slave trade at one point in the 17th
century the Dutch West India Company was
the largest transatlantic slave trader
Mark rooted today apologizing to anyone
who suffered including those who were
enslaved and their descendants Redmond
Shannon now on the apology and why many
say it's not enough
the Hague home of the international
criminal court on Monday the city saw
the Dutch prime minister himself issue a
historic apology for what he calls a
crime against humanity
for centuries the Dutch State enabled
and stimulated slavery and profited from
it human beings were made into
Commodities exploited and abused
today I apologize Mark Ruta says those
alive today are not responsible but
descendants of slaves still live with
the consequences government ministers
visited former colonies to make similar
statements over different periods the
Dutch Empire conquered land across the
globe in North and South America the
Caribbean western and southern Africa
south Asia and what is now Indonesia
ruta's apology was recommended in a
report published last year commissioned
in the wake of the worldwide racial
Justice protests after the murder of
George Floyd in the United States the
prime minister's words received a mixed
reaction from voters the excuses those
apologies came too late there is so much
suffering and hatred for slavery it
cannot be settled in one day
for years Caribbean countries have been
seeing any settlement must include
Financial reparations from former
colonizers including Britain and France
quite literally these European states
are founded in large part on the slave
trade
um the naval and political power that
came from the slave trade and on
Imperial rivalry countries like the
Netherlands have tried to avoid the
question of reparations coming from
former colonies like Suriname the debate
is controversial even as Dutch attitudes
to history change this year King Willem
Alexander said Royals will no longer use
a golden Carriage featuring images of
slavery there are calls that he
apologized to but it has to be an
apology that doesn't come with the whiff
of avoidance
of deeper issues for now the Dutch
government has promised funding to
awareness projects and the slavery
Museum Redmond Shannon Global News
London
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Sophie Louis tonight's your Canada
is the ring art installation in Montreal
it's 30 meters in diameter and weighs a
hefty 23 000 kilos or 50 000 pounds
thanks for watching and have yourselves
a great night
[Music]